So now that we have our text in place
for our ad, we need to add our keywords.
These are the foundation
of your ad group.
Your ad has a possibility of
appearing in the top search results
when people search these keywords.
Google recommends starting with 10
to 20 keywords that are specific to
phrases that your potential
customers may use when searching for
your product or service.
Google also recommends
avoiding 1 word keywords.
Which if you think about it makes sense.
Imagine if we use the keyword, dog.
Think of everything that
can be related to that.
Dog health info, blogs about dogs,
news articles relating to dogs.
Videos of dogs, things on Animal Planet,
buying a dog, cute dog pictures,
hot dogs, being sick as a dog, getting
a little hair of the dog, dog whistles,
dog parks types of dogs, I could go
on but I think you get the picture.
Non of these have anything
to do with dog sitting.
To avoid that chaos you can use
Google Trends Keyword Planner
that we went over previously to help you
choose the keyboards you want to use.
So let's send in our keywords.
After we've filled out our app, I'm
going to scroll down to make keywords.
We'll go with dog sitting, luxury
dog sitting, dog care, pet sitting,
pet care, home dog sitting,
in home dog sitting, dog services,
pet sitter, dog sitter, pet hotel, what
to do with my dog while on vacation.
And we can add more.
Before we move on let's hear from Chris,
a marketing expert about
choosing keywords, and
then Andrea, an ad words expert about
figuring out our budget and bidding.
So we'll be ready to launch our ad.